[Music]
it is looking really bad in Russia right
now Russia has lost about 56 000 troops
are setting untrained Personnel
Putin just announced a mandatory
military draft because he needs more
troops in Ukraine and Russian citizens
are not having it authorities threaten
one protester with 10 years in jail if
he refused to enlist massive protests
and riots have erupted all over Russia
arsonists have set fire to military
draft centers officers have been
attacked with at least one being shot
and the Russian police are showing no
mercy protesters are being beaten and
dragged off over 2 300 people have been
arrested already and now Russians are
trying to escape the country as fast as
possible head borders in Russia's East
South and West thousands of Russian men
are trying to escape conscription
Russians are scrambling to fly to places
like Istanbul or Dubai with flights from
Moscow to those destinations reaching as
high as nine thousand dollars for a
one-way economy ticket at its peak other
rushes are trying to drive their way out
of Russia with border crossings to
Finland Georgia Kazakhstan and Mongolia
being backed up for miles upon miles
with cars lines of cars stretched
several kilometers earlier we covered
how Russia shut off his main gas
pipeline to Europe with the goal of
freezing Europe into submission this
winter well now it looks like they just
exploded that Pipeline on purpose so
Europe has zero chance of Ever Getting
Russian gas again this may be the result
of an attack or some kind of sabotage so
winter is coming and Europe and Russia
are now in a race a race to see who
breaks first will Europe break first
from its Rising Energy prices and civil
unrest or will Russia break for us from
not having enough troops in civil unrest
stay dangerous and let's get into it
[Music]
have you ever wondered why you keep
seeing ads for e-commerce Brands like
athletic greens it's because they make
an obscene amount of money Dr squash
with those funny bar soap ads make over
a hundred million dollars a year dude
wipes who literally just sells wipes is
valid at 300 million dollars a year
while athletic greens they're valued at
over a billion dollars it's insane so if
you're looking to start a new business
or side hustle you should definitely
consider e-commerce but if you're gonna
do this you're gonna need super fast
efficient and affordable shipping that
is where ship station comes in today's
video sponsorship station is hands down
the easiest most efficient and most
affordable shipping software available
today there's a reason why over a
hundred thousand e-commerce Merchants
worldwide are using shipstation it's so
reliable that 98 of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it for
as long as they're in business they give
you access to the best shipping carriers
at highly discounted rates that are
usually only available to Giant
companies you can ship anywhere in the
the world it works with over 300
different platforms like Amazon Etsy and
more and it helps you automate pretty
much every shipping test with just a few
clicks and you can even handle orders on
your phone plus it's also available in
the UK Australia and Canada start saving
time and money on shipping today by
heading over to shipstation.com with the
link below for a 60-day free trial
that's two whole months of Cheaper
stress-free shipping totally free pause
the video and go to shipstation.com with
the link below shift station makeshift
happen
[Music]
September was not a good month for the
Russian military Ukrainian forces took
back thousands of square miles of
territory and Russia has lost a lot of
soldiers either from deaths capture or
just soldiers straight up running away
so Putin's forces have found themselves
stretched thin across hundreds of miles
of Ukrainian territory at the same time
Russia is trying to hold a vote in four
conquered regions of Ukraine to see if
they want to become part of Russia if
these regions are allowed to join Russia
Putin will be able to call any attempt
to regain those areas a direct attack
against Russia itself and he's made it
clear he's not afraid to go nuclear if
that were to happen
so Putin is running out of soldiers
during this critical moment in the war
they've already resorted to recruiting
men in prison to fight in Ukraine but
that is just not enough so on September
21st Putin announced a mandatory
military draft technically this draft is
only a partial mobilization only people
in Army Reserves or with previous
military experience are supposed to be
called to fight
but remember Russia hasn't done any type
of mandatory mobilization like this
since World War II and now there are
reports coming in that even
inexperienced civilians are getting
draft papers some men are reporting
they've received draft notices even if
they don't qualify due to their age or
even if they've never served in the
military reports are saying certain
ethnic groups are being conscripted more
than others and although official
Reports say the goal was 300 000 new
recruits many suspect the real number is
much much higher
so for the first time the war in Ukraine
is finally directly affecting the lives
of Russian citizens and it ignited chaos
in Russia
[Music]
Putin has never had a good track record
of respecting Free Speech but he took it
to a whole new level after he invaded
Ukraine last February the following
month he signed a law declaring that
fake news about the war or even
protesting the war could be punished
with up to 15 years in prison so up
until last week most Russians knew to
keep their mouth shut even if many of
them especially the younger generation
don't support the war but now it's
gotten real families are being ripped
apart sons are being sent off to the
battlefield so Russians are finally
standing up all over Russia military
recruitment offices have been attacked
and set on fire one draft officer was
shot point blank in Siberia the
thousands that have been arrested from
the protests are now facing a 15-year
prison sentence people who refuse the
draft are facing the same sentence how
to break your arm became a top Google
Trend after Putin's announcement for
those hoping to be excused from the
draft for having a broken arm
but an even bigger Google search Trend
in Russia is now how to leave
young Russian men and their families are
escaping the country in swarms flights
out of the country to pretty much every
destination are completely sold out
and when they're not sold out the prices
get a little inflated like this 45-hour
flight with three layovers for a family
of three to Johannesburg how much did it
cost fifty thousand dollars
they're all flooding into any nearby
country that offers visa-free travel for
Russians turkey Georgia and Armenia have
all been flooded those driving to nearby
countries can expect lines at border
checkpoints to be as long as 12 miles
people were reporting having to wait 8
10 even 12 hours to cross and as of
writing some wait times to cross into
Georgia are up to 48 hours but in our
opinion a 48-hour wait time is still a
lot better than dying in Ukraine while
some neighboring countries like
Lithuania Latvia Estonia and the Czech
Republic are denying them entry
altogether
Vladimir Putin has made it clear that
he's willing to go further than anyone
else's to get what he wants but the
United States has also been very willing
to take things to an extreme when
they're pushed to the edge One Moment in
history when America was pushed to the
edge was with the war on terror the CIA
was so desperate to capture the bad guys
that they launched America's very own
torture program and it was brutal and
and very illegal their torture
techniques were so brutal that it's way
darker than anything we've covered on
this channel before but 2001 and 2009
hundreds if not thousands of Arabic men
and women were kidnapped sent to CIA
black sites all over the world to be
enhanced interrogated by the CIA all
without ever charging them with a crime
the black site program was one of the
darkest periods in America's history but
no school or university will ever tell
you the full story the problem is a
public YouTube video about this would
definitely get demonetized which is why
we've released a full-length documentary
on the cia's black site program that you
can watch right now by clicking the join
button below when you join you'll get
access to this documentary and many
others that are too controversial to
ever be posted publicly and channel
members have been loving these private
documentaries and the best part is that
unlike University you get all this
Insider knowledge that they'll never
teach you for only five dollars a month
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most YouTube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of
the first time and we will personally
refund you for your first month after
your first month there is no refund
[Music]